if you like slept one of my girlfriends
or something you can tell me that like I
don't care well that that settles that
are we done yet
hi I'm Jeremy I'm Justin and today we're
playing never ever ever ever have I ever
excited I hope and pray that I know
everything about her
if she doesn't surprise me with some
crazy things I can't wait to learn some
stuff about him that I might not know
I'm scared to learn some stuff about no
I would say he keeps secrets yeah
because we're twins we pretty much know
everything about one another but I think
for me there are some things that I will
be taking to my grave we're born a year
in less than a year and a half apart so
I would say we're as close as siblings
can be and we choose to be friends as
adults which is cool all right let's get
at it I can't think of anything specific
but I'm pretty sure yes for sure for
sure
I'm pretty sure there's a lot of things
I've ever done that I blamed you for
yeah I'm sure you have because I took
the flack for you a lot yeah that was
bad he was a bad you got in trouble in
like fifth grade for tripping a girl
totally me that did that and then like
she's like what's your name and I was
like Jeremy I will say I have Kayla
Kayla likes to go out at night
past 12 o'clock and she don't tell our
parents my mom likes to hit me up and
I'd be like hey you know Kayla she's
with me right now she's in my room I
have we were gonna go to Disneyland and
Jeremy ate the chocolate cake or
something
the night before we went and left of
just a giant mess the day before we're
going to Disneyland and my dad is like I
we're not going anywhere until somebody
admits who did this and then Jeremy had
the audacity
you should go ahead you should be like
you should really like step up have not
I have I'm sure I've taken the fall for
you
I mean anytime you were a little and you
would like do something really messed up
wasn't the baby actually I'm gonna
rotate this to like I have not and any
chance of your younger sibling has an
opportunity to take the fall for
something that you did by all means do
that let's say I have not I try not to
lie I try to keep it real with the
siblings yeah at the very wise are for
everyone else parents yeah I would say I
have I trained to believing that he
needed to go outside naked and I locked
him outside of the house and the only
way I let him back into the house is if
he ran around the neighborhood naked
Kayla always like oh casino you you oh
you owe me this you owe me that and I'm
like hey I don't owe you anything you
didn't buy that for me and I and I know
deep down inside they Caleb paid $400
worth of stuff for me I have not you
better put I had like go ahead and put
that up there he does it now I wear
office all the time
my closet is trash she is known to her
math have better fashionable items she's
more stylish than I am her shoe closet
is way better than mine
I will not
oh that's problem I probably have like
he doesn't now like my brother thinks
that everything is that's mine is also
his so they're like you got two
wardrobes yeah actually like ended up
stealing your Shack shorts remember the
shack shorts you know two pairs of
basketball shorts cuz we rep Shack we
like shack everyone hates out loud
you have it I have he says he has I've
never heard anybody call him a favor
I'm definitely my mom's favorite I'm
definitely her least favorite I mean
I've been favorited I was never I'm a
teacher's pet parents she does
everything me on the other hand it's
like okay I'll get to it when I do it if
you rush me to do something I'm not
gonna do it I think a serving everybody
knows you lost that when you got drunk
and fell flat on her face that husband
favorite I I don't think I mean I lead
is not as big as it once was
Oh which which one the last one yeah I
think everyone unfortunately this guy
because when I didn't like them I made
it very clear that I did it I for sure I
do not like and I must say this with
infants ability to save the babies I do
not like the person that you think was
they didn't thank God I mean I don't
like most of your girlfriends
so I mean either most of the time the
girls that my brother has picked up in
pretty harmless so there's a weird way
to wear it that I always want to hang
any time any day any hour don't get much
time to anymore because I got kids but I
come through I grow up one day and then
I'll be out of the house yes and then
and then we'll hang out all the time cuz
I won't have kids I had younger I wasn't
I wanted to be as cool as I could be and
I didn't think my brother was cool at
this age it's rare you see be a Kayla
hang out together you go out and do your
own thing I go out and do my own thing
and then you know we want to hang out
and get gate we can as I got older I
realize like in high school of course
like he was one of my best friends but
younger I thought again it's like you're
nerd not somebody that like a lot of
people associate with people associate
with me the end game was to make sure
that we both were in a position to where
people who really were accepting of who
we are moved to a new state and
unfortunately for that to happen I had
to like kind of separate myself from him
yeah we'll talk every talk even we first
we fight yes but we make up at the end
of the day no I don't think so I think
the longest we've ever gone without
talking is probably a week by like we we
do social media together yeah this dude
calls me every day yeah I called him
just to remind him like how much he
sucks every day okay really quick just
before you get off the phone don't
forget that you suck all right take care
I mean it he says something worse than
that but I'm sure you can all imagine
that's fake news our siblings we all
have a group chat the sibyl's the
sibyl's yeah the bird Sybil so we talk
pretty regularly we'll be dead mad but
we'll still text each other yeah like
hey I brought you some food come eat
this yeah don't call me but you can take
that respond no keep it in private I
would die yeah yeah her hayden
Panettiere I'm not gonna lie like we get
to get dirty I'm gonna exploratory stage
in my life my question escalated things
very quickly mm-hmm I'm the rainbow
shade I would say I don't I don't think
they call me the black sheep it's like
the rainbow she I feel like I'm
different from everybody yeah I think me
and my mom my mom think she's a black
sheep but I think I'm like sheep because
I'm always I'm different
I don't think that there's somebody else
in our family odd one out can you tell I
think he'll have some more lives I do
not know bringing to the forefront I
said in the beginning there are some
things I'm going to attain to my grave
it's kind of funny I think that this is
I open that you are a good brother I'll
be a review because apparently 90% of
what you do is manipulating me it's good
business
you're my favorite person I've been
adult person okay I got the little ones
my Road Dogg for life G [ __ ] died
[Music]